so today we're gonna answer the question
should you drink water before going to
bed and the answer is no you should okay
why there's actually two reasons number
one drinking more water is gonna make
you get up to the night and that's gonna
interfere with your sleep okay so we
don't want to do that so an average
bladder can hold a little more than a
cup and a half of urine before certain
receptors are triggered forcing you to
get up in urinate and there are people
that have to get up through the night
and urinate for other reasons because if
you're a diabetic it's gonna increase
urinary frequency if you're taking
diuretics that's gonna do it if you have
a prostate problem and by the way as a
side note if you have a prostate problem
just to avoid dairy and see if your
prostate problem gets a lot better
because you may have prostatitis which
is an inflammatory condition which could
be triggered by dairy but that's a
separate video and then you have a
fibroid which is a mass pressing on your
bladder or a condition called hyper
Calci mia could do it as well i have a
separate video on that you can watch
that okay so number one we don't want to
drink before you go to bed because it's
gonna interfere with our sleep number
two dry fasting okay now this is going
to be my watered-down version of dry
fasting and no pun intended were you
gonna do not a really long dry fast and
by the way a dry fast basically means
you're fasting without drinking any
water so the benefits of fasting are
huge but when you do dry fasting they're
enhanced even more of course to a point
because you can't go too long without
drinking water before you die but what
happens when you do fasting is it
triggers certain types of survival
mechanisms that actually then cause this
adaptation and these great survival
benefits that occur and doing a dry fast
also helps that so my recommendation is
to not drink pass let's say six or maybe
seven o'clock at night and that will
give you a good enough time to be able
to empty your bladder let's say an hour
and a half later and then maybe one more
time before you go to bed and then
you'll get the benefits of the sleep
plus the benefit
of some dry fasting okay because you're
doing a version of this you're not going
24 hours you can drink in the next day
but it is a mini version of dry fasting
to a certain degree so it will give you
some benefits and also realize that your
body can can actually turn some of the
fat into water so when you're burning
fat you are releasing some water as well
all right guys I wanted to keep this
really quick I'll see in the next video
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that